hello everyone welcome to the 50th
episode of play watch listen
i'm alana pierce that's us austin i did
it wrong again
austin wintry video game composer that
is greg miller video game voice actor
and that
is mike bethel video game director hi
so much i'm so we're so excited to have
our 50th episode
here today we've come a long way
it's it's yeah it's been what nearly a
year now yeah
i guess i've got saying over here that
seems usually how it works yeah
you guys generally all right greg stop
greg always you do this every time
i don't mean to write you but it's i
feel like it's just 50 49 episodes of me
coming in and having to really tell you
all right i thought i
figured out this i got the link to
discord
are you ready are you guys ready who was
that like
i was on i was sitting i think our wires
are crossed um
he had a really good performance in a
mike bithell game that's all i'm saying
is
i was like what if i took what if i put
on glasses
and then i took it off it's like it's
you don't have the
you don't have that it's not the magic
what's the magic there's a lot you know
there's careers that are going up and
then there's careers that are going down
troy
for a long time 2013 was the apex of it
and then it's just kind of been this
i got a little bump on uncharted 4 and
then it's like yeah
did we really need a brother
before overstaffed wasn't it really yeah
don't you have a channel to run
yeah get out of here congratulations on
your 50th episode everybody have a good
day
the perspective changed in a way i
didn't expect it to oh i have to adjust
the video this is all messed up that's
typically what happens with me is that i
bring about a perspective
change very hot yeah are definitely so
far
this is [ __ ] this is a mixing
challenge of an episode so far
automatically automatically i call
[ __ ] here's life magic there we go
here we go
every and every episode 50 at
49 in alana pierce is all
bundled up in a nice little green screen
jumper
bundled oh austin wintry
has something above you
has whatever swag hoodie
mike bithell just mike
his his changes
it's nice and cloudy in the los angeles
area i'm going to wear i'm going to look
like everybody else and i'm going to
wear a hoodie and everyone comes in
looking like we're in the [ __ ]
bahamas right now
it's pretty warm today it is what do you
want me to say
it is it's oh it's overcast it makes me
feel like we live in portland
yeah it's true i i uh i like these
drizzly
la days you have to enjoy them while
they last
yeah do you write differently if it's if
it's cloudy or moody or weather or do
you not really even
take stock notice or whatever you do
more
who you talking about what's everybody
where am i well i guess it applies to
all of us isn't it
i'm more productive when it's raining
really
yeah why because there's nothing pulling
you compelling you outside yeah not that
i even go outside i just feel like i
think about it a lot
you just spent a lot of time being like
what if i went outside
and i don't but you get the idea
um what about you
i'm freezing my camera is already messed
up it's
like cold
i'm so used to rubbish weather anyway
like it makes no difference
yeah so this is why we don't usually use
discord um but we did it so i could
adjust
the levels for for the live everyone
thank you for joining us here today
everyone um to celebrate
50 episodes of this lovely little show
that we have been doing
confirmed over a year um
is it confirmed was that official it's
definitely how much
i'm not sure how much of what just
happened was canon we can probably get
them back honestly we'll probably make
it happen
uh but i did i did have some questions
that i wanted to ask one troy
did you ever play more than the train
jedi fall in order
excellent uh mike how's the last of us
going
um exactly as it was yeah don't give me
[ __ ]
um i finished the uh uh a plague tale
so what yeah i went out there and i done
did it
when did you die have you been hanging
on to this trivia
i finished it last weekend specifically
for the show
i thought it was excellent i really
really liked it and it seems bizarre to
me that last
that not so many people are talking
about it like i know you and elise
williams are the two who've always told
me to play that game
well you know it's those w's we know
what's going on
it's true the wintry's the williams is
uh
yes it cost over a million units sold so
it wasn't a failure by any stretch but
it wasn't
as ecstatically talked about as i
thought it would be after i played it
and realized this is
quite good i really enjoyed the crazy
the crazy semi-spoilers very much
spoilers the crazy
uh tornado boss fight at the end
is just so over the top but it kind of
earns it by the time you get there and i
just
i yeah i loved it i feel so vindicated
that you finish
it it's i feel like i've made my mark on
society now and like now we get to
have great hope replace you it'll be
great
i um i uh
my version of homework which i already
reported
was finishing the good place which i did
ages ago and also which is nice
yeah well that's because you're the best
of us clearly
uh you're the only one who's really
committed so we really appreciate that
oh as far as like completing your menial
task mm-hmm
that just meant broadly speaking did you
finish uh mandalorian troy
yes okay well yeah that's good that's
good
austin's low i don't know that i believe
any of you he seems fine to me
really austin's completely freezed on my
screen i'm assuming i've frozen on yours
right
you're you're just low frame rate yeah
you're very jumpy you're like a
19 1920s film reel
okay these i don't complete with green
and
uh and all the uh
yeah yeah i i just say how disconcerting
that is when i can't see you actually
reaching for the piano
if we're doing updates i i provided you
a little elan if you can show it but i
have a splinter update
do we want to do a splinter update uh
yeah i could show that
if you twitter splinter
splinter is this squirrel that came to
us on his literally his like last leg
and he was with this guy he had a
forward down
three out of four were down he was he
was a death's door
and we have a little squirrel table
interestingly he came to your door
i came to our door it's like that's not
where you go go to the hospital pretty
sure that just means you're death
you said that's don't worry yeah you are
your door
um i don't know you want the two that's
two doors down um
oh that's the band we're just purgatory
oh hi
nice to meet you how is it it's okay
um so he came to us and this was about
at the beginning of quarantine really so
it's been you know
almost a year uh and this little plucky
guy
has stuck it out and we've got a little
squirrel table that we put
food and and uh other little various
sundries we have a special
bag of stuff just for uh it's heroin uh
for
for splinter but he comes and i've seen
him
uh run all the way down the length of
another person's lawn
once we call him like hey be good
looking and he comes running up and
he'll come and eat right out of my hand
and he's just he's fully back to health
curious this is a really good picture
that's pam she took that photo shoot she
is a photographer
she lets she you know splitter just eats
out of her hands let's just take
pictures should i be able to see this
right now
no uh no it's just on the live stream
it'll be there in a second if you want
to look at the live streams we'll watch
we'll
when we watch the show later we'll we'll
see it then you guys want to watch
do you guys re-watch the show i
absolutely never do
no i'm joking okay guys
i come across i i don't re-watch but i
do
uh thoroughly enjoy perusing the
comments
yeah same cool yeah i definitely enjoy
the comments of the show but
uh the show itself when i re-watched
myself that's ridiculous did you see him
yeah he's up there right now
looks like blender is missing an ear
also
uh he's pretty busted the reason why we
called him splinters because he looked
like master
and someone was like splinter was rat
i'm like yeah i know dude he looked like
a rat he looked like a drowned rat when
we first found him
uh but splinter
that is that is quite plagued it is
really taking it back there
uh i felt like that check that out i
felt like the um
[Music]
the skull was awesome as well austin i
imagine that's the thing that resonated
with you the the music in that it was
lovely yeah i wonder how it actually
scored
olivier de riviera wrote the score
and olivier but i will say i i think we
may have spoken about this once before i
do have beef with games doing
word word colin word could it not have
just been plague tale did it have to be
plague tale calling innocence
i thought it was innocent is it because
of trademarks
usually that would be my guess yeah we
had a young lady
yeah generally you have to say that
there was a situation in the game that
i'm that i'm working on they had the
same thing they're like well they
own xyz but if you do xyz
colon boom then it's yours
sometimes it's optimistic franchising
you know
yeah right you could go play tail colin
not
innocence the the spicy sequel
yeah you joke but like often that's part
of the conversation especially when
you're getting like a publisher
or a deal like you do have to like have
a plan for like what if we want to go
further with this
i actually do is that a publisher thing
or is that a developer call who who
calls that
on whether a game gets a sequel no no no
on whether
this is what we're going to call it like
do you go
in a healthy relationship it's kind of a
collaboration i think usually
um yeah sorry i just is my signal in a
dictorial sense
i mean demand for sequels i'm sure is
certainly a thing that you know we've
heard of happening in the games industry
that publisher demanded a sequel
uh and i imagine that could be really
tough yeah it can be demanded in the
contract it can be something that's like
forced on people yeah potentially
i remember like we didn't call it the
last of us until
we we've been filming for a while like
it was still originally called the first
of us right it was called the first
and they were like well that doesn't
work um just missed the initial
launch date so it had to change it was
an adam and eve game and they really
changed things along the way
it was plaid shirt man for a while it
was an adam and eve uh
dlc of assassin's creed that just got
thoroughly thoroughly naughty dog was
like we will take that
very into it how by the way guys
i gotta show you this kerry made us or
made
made cakes but she made me a special
little cake where's mine and she also
gave me her blow torch
um i'm scared
this is the end of mike we're all gonna
witness it live this is some
this is yeah this is live content oh
look at that there we go
wait did you start the fire in your
neighborhood
[Laughter]
this would be the evidence that would be
used against me so there you go
is that a 50th episode it's a 50th
episode cupcake there you go
oh that looks lovely is it like red
velvet some kind of red velvet situation
so so this was my question um it's not
red velvet we're making do because it's
quarantine it looks like red velvet but
it doesn't
it doesn't have the cream cheese
apparently yeah i like the skillet
i'll um afford my shipping address to
carry
if that's cool i would like to
by the time it gets to you in the
current climate especially with brexit
and the
uh increased uh work of the ports it'll
be yeah
a little bit old i imagine by that point
but i i would like the candle lit on
arrival
by the way i i i hope for a very slow
burning candle that can can sit like in
a
beauty in the beast glass jar but going
down so
slowly that it arrives still going do
you have to declare that at customs if
the thing you're
uh sending was
now that you've told us you actually
have to keep it lit uh we just need you
to fill out this form
um alana the one thing that is like you
you've i don't know which
has changed more my hats or your mics
because you have a new microphone go
through three yeah i mean it's your
microphone
um this is the the wave three which most
of my friends use
and i like it a whole lot um it's the
only mic
that i have that has got me away from
like i'm a i'm a super hardcore audio
nerd
to usb and it's a usb mic and it's
awesome yeah i like it a lot um but i
had
i'm having this issue the last three
times i've tried to use it where i have
to unplug it and plug it back in or it
just
my computer just has no levels uh
that's a tech support
i would also say i don't think i've had
my kitchen in the background for any
other episodes but here we are no it's a
different at least you have the
cyberbunk chair
so we can uh you know yeah we can set
aside
here we gonna talk about that wow is
that awful
um yeah i mean we can so so
cd projekt red tweeted yesterday i sent
it to you guys
yeah that was the first thing i saw when
i woke up this morning was your
message i felt like it was it was it was
very similar to like harrison's ford
speech in air force one at the very
beginning he's like
we will not negotiate we will not be
afraid
it's your turn to be afraid how does he
do it you know i just don't understand
how he does
how does harrison ford do that
little energy yeah possible yeah my
secretary of state in that in that
uh scene is so great he's just like
well you just did it didn't you i want a
president i want a president like that
you want to know my favorite trivia
about that movie
wolfgang peterson directed that film he
did and
it had an original a different
soundtrack yes do you know
i said podcast deja vu did i bring that
up on this before
you 100 did yeah we've done it live damn
it god damn it
there's no way i would have found out
any other context of this podcast
well it's such a perfect it's such a
perfect uh no no no
that's good yeah i would have read in
the comments
that this was
we think that's what started it's like
in the um it's like in the simpsons when
they show the trailer for the itchy and
scratchy movie and the very end says
movie contains 25 additional footage or
something like that we're
basically all there already uh but yes
our dear randy newman
wrote the original air force one score
and uh
you guys were praying he was replaced
let's
oh incredible
what i love is that troy has it's like
at this point troy is so committed to
the brand
of hating randy newman that even if he
secretly loves him he would never admit
it publicly i can't
i'm too committed to this you're on my
deathbed it's like this confessions
of of everything will be like and i
loved randy newman
and austin would be like [ __ ] i knew it
i knew it all along um president
got all
i mean we could just do this for the
rest of the episode that seems fine to
me
this is what the audience wants yes this
is the content i'm cool with it
i love that it was a very short road
it was a very short road from uh cdpr
to troy singing as randy all right let's
circle back to that because one of the
most
serious things that's happened in the
games industry it's just
incredibly brutal and you're like you've
got
so they tweeted at about midnight uh
pacific time last night
yesterday we discovered that we have
become a victim of a targeted cyber
attack due to which some of our internal
systems have been compromised an
unidentified actor gained
unauthorized act and a lot of people
have been thrown off by actor it just
means
person who acted upon a thing not an
actual it's not troy yeah
i wonder for a second if it was like
when i was an actual actor
because then i started thinking about it
as like this is like a message that you
get from the matrix and so i started
drawing all these conclusions about
for some reason uh gain unauthorized
access to our internal network collected
certain data belonging to cd projekt
capital group and left a ransom note the
content of
which we will be released to the public
although some devices in our network
have been encrypted our backups remain
intact we have already secured our it
infrastructure and begun restoring the
data um they said they won't negotiate
they're still investigating etc and they
also publish the ransom note
which says hello cd projekt you have
been epically pawned
which oh my gosh really nails the
demographic of the hacker
oh so we're looking for a millennial
no i don't think millennials say porn i
think you've got to be
you've got to be 40 to say that word
these days but i don't know
millennials are getting up there now
like the millennials are nearly in 40
right
i think i'm a millennial i am 27. so
almost i'm a millennial and i'm sorry
but all these isn't there at least a
10-year range to all these labels
yeah that's true um they continued we
have dumped full copies of the source
codes from your perforce server
for cyberpunk 2077 witcher 3 gwen and
the unreleased version of the witcher 3.
we have also dumped all of your
documents really into accounting
administration legal hr investor
relations and more
also we have encrypted all of your
servers but we understand that you can
most likely recover from backups which
they did
uh if we will not come to an agreement
then your source codes will be sold or
leaked online and your documents will be
sent to our
contacts and gaming journalism your
public image will go down the shitty
even more and people will see how shitty
your company functions
investors will lose trust in your
company and the stock will die even
lower 48 hours contact us so
i now being in dev read this
and read the word perforce and was like
oh my [ __ ] god
um this is real absolutely mortifying
uh the idea that this could happen is is
truly [ __ ] terrifying but i feel like
mike you're probably the best person to
speak to
what would happen if uh everything that
cd projekt had ever worked on all their
source code
was leaked online what does that
actually mean
i mean it means i think the source code
aspect means exactly what
people would expect it means like it
means that you'd have access to every
asset
um in the game you'd also presumably
they would also
have all of the assets used to make the
games all the art assets all the stuff
that
the the working files so you know if you
think about like the
word processor you use and then you
export a pdf it would be both the pdf
and then the word document as well so
it'll be all the work leading up to the
game
the bit that really matters in my
opinion in the bit that's really scary
is all that hr
stuff all of that private information
about employees so they said that's the
thing though to the best of their
ability and that's the only reason i
didn't bring it up is you know the thing
that is
clearly the most important is my brain
goes to am i going to get doxed
they have my home address um but they
did say
very probably well no they said that the
compromise system did not
contain any personal data about players
or use of services
it is entirely possible that uh any
parties that may have been affected
due to the breach that they said they're
contacting them but i don't know
they i have no idea if this uh affects
you know a lot of the people i know who
work there it's it's brutal but i feel
like that part is probably okay and i
feel like if it weren't i probably
would have received an email i hope so
does it precipitate or necessitate
rather a
complete like that has engine
that has everything so in order to
do you have to like burn like
you or if you say thanks to austin
wintry uh
who i believe you guys have met the
whole thing of gene hackman in
in enemy of the state where he was like
you made a phone call
you made a phone call uh and he torches
his entire place and he's like
i was secure for 25 years is it that
kind of thing was like we have to burn
this thing down and completely rebuild
it back up
because if we don't there could always
be a back door into our system because
someone would have the source code they
would have
everything it was is is it that
fundamental and widespread
i would think source code for the same
network
well we also even if the source code
leaks uh it no it's not the same as
network access not that that
it seems like they've got everything
they needed but they're not it wouldn't
be them leaking network access to
everyone
um the source code isn't necessarily
useful if we don't have all of their
tools as well
uh but i mean again we might have that
as well
they could yeah we don't know um it
essentially means that everything that
they've ever made is available to
absolutely everyone which devalues
everything they've made but i don't know
that this has happened before
um not in this space with games before
right
i think games have happened like this
before well
is it potentially a bluff is it possible
like can they verify that they have this
well
uh they verified i mean i think this is
true
they they put a readme note
in their system um so they did
definitely get in
yeah and they did also lock stuff down
which they did have to
um have a backup you know their devices
access to a server if you can if you can
save a file to a server then you've got
everything
you need to read you could no one can
write to a server without being able to
also read from a server and copy stuff
off so now copy that
there so do you think that what their
play of like we will not negotiate with
terrorists
is the right play or like what
what's the collateral damage of of doing
that i mean there's there's
well everything we've done with
terrorists
yeah but the the that needs to be said
the people that are doing this are no
matter i don't care what you find out
about cd projekt red
there is nothing you can find out that's
going to make them look worse than you
um this isn't cool there's nothing
that's
laudable about this um you're
it's your despicable person uh it's a
despicable act i will say that i i will
not
qualify them but it's a despicable act
um that is irredeemable um
the the notion though of going fine
we're just gonna let this happen
and try to pull the punch i don't know
what the play is
i don't know if it's it's you know what
we're going to i mean clearly they've
owned it
and said we're we're not negotiating and
we're going to let this happen that's
the play
so it's either balls in your court and
either put up or shut up
which the only thing i can think of this
is all speculation is that they don't
think that they actually have
all of the no it's that they have all of
the information forever meaning that if
you negotiate with them once they could
just
get that for the rest of your life like
they are always going to have that
source code you can't
get the source code off of them it
doesn't work that way so they are always
forever going to be able to be like give
us a million dollars a month
they have to just be like you do
whatever you're gonna do yeah i would
say that that that was
my instinct also is that there's an
instant recognition of
we can't undo what's been done so we we
may as well
shore up our our preparation for
whatever the
response will be at least you know i i
feel bad for
those folks they've had it they've had a
hell i mean say what
you want about the what you think of the
game they've gotten their ass handed to
him
well and and also setting aside you know
the the debate about the nature of
management and
and because i i don't know i'm not
inside i have i have
i only see what people say and i refuse
to judge people i don't know
internally and and all that but i do
know from the people i do know that
there obviously in the music department
um everyone
really is doing their best really trying
to
to make something great and outperform
their already excellent
game track record and and um and god
talking
in the midst of a global pandemic in the
midst of all of that
yeah talk about a um talk about a um
it's just been such a bad 12 months
for those people it's it sucks um
especially if they were in conditions
that that led to crunch that makes it
all even worse like this happening to
people who are working their asses off
when they didn't need to be as even is
even worse it just gets worse and worse
it's just so brutal but uh like i i
agree trey this is
absolutely irredeemable a truly
disgusting thing to do that no matter
how you feel about the game it's like
i'm never gonna be like this is the
right thing to do put them to the ground
absolutely not this is real people like
if you have beef you probably have beef
with alpha management not with the
individual people who are
broadly affected by this and having
their lives work leaked online but um
upper management won't be in any way
directly affected by either
they're still getting bonuses but the
entire the entire team whose hr records
are in there if that
is the case and we'll see then that's a
horrible thing
yeah i really i really hope that's not
the case um but yeah to double back
mike what what do you think actually
happens if if
you know the witcher 3 source code is is
leaked online what does that mean
honestly technically i would guess not a
lot because ultimately i mean i'm
assuming
all these games are already pirated
anyway so you can if you if you want to
play any of these games without paying
fully moddable how about it right like
all multiple
you've got every like everything's
actually out there from like a
most user's point of view so i guess
there's
theoretically like a competitor could
get a look under the hood but again
like the games industry generally and i
guess that will bring us eventually to
the the other big topic of the week
i was going to say this is a great segue
secrets
yeah most secrets in game dev don't stay
secret very long there
there's a gdc talk there's a there's a
conversation down the bar between two
respect
respected people like ultimate companies
have probably just in terms of
there's explicit sharing like like yeah
you know like come on over to our studio
so we can show you how this thing works
we know you're working on something kind
of similar like i hear stories like that
all the time amongst steps
so it's impossible it's embarrassing but
it's really cool
second sony's really collaborative it's
really cool yeah
no everyone will have already learned
all of this i think
i think honestly it's embarrassing it's
it's
if there is like you know personnel data
legal data that kind of stuff
it's very telling that like when the
sony leaks happen for example
i i assume that included a bunch of
footage of movies and stuff like that
was it sony it was sony wasn't it yeah
yeah but the stuff that was actually
headlines the stuff that was actually
damaging to sony was all the email
records was all the kind of all of the
stuff that was
more like salary negotiation kind of
[ __ ]
yeah so i i'd imagine that's the more
damaging stuff rather than
what's on their hard drives with the
game like that's that stuff ultimately
hackers have already probably gleaned
most of the stuff that's interesting
from
cyberpunk already i would assume in that
again the game is already muddable it's
you know that is already a thing we can
do i guess at least
this wasn't october that this happened
or you know imagine imagine with
everything going on that's where we've
had a material impact right because that
would have
proceeded the game coming out and
selling all the all the copies it did so
yeah
i don't know i'm sure i'm sure i'm wrong
i'm sure there's layers to this that i'd
be missing but
uh yeah
there's a different point between like
here you can play the game for free that
would obviously have had an impact
but if it had come out right before the
game was going to ship
there's still pre-orders there i don't
know i mean i guess you could cancel
your pre-orders but people who don't
pre-order and
and by day one or by week after that
that surely been
impacted but wouldn't have made too much
of a difference because
it's it's really the console version
that is a major problem
uh so you even if even if you could
rip the code and play the game it would
have technically been the same thing
reviewers played which i think you know
overall got like an eight or something
like i don't think it's the console
version but they're
funny to imagine impacted
[Music]
how are you presenting it it's like
someone running down the street with the
with the all of the ingredients to a
cake you still got to [ __ ] bake it
but what i was going to say was the the
the impact uh
of the leaks for the last of us did not
have an impact on the sales
yeah at least that we can measure who's
to say
but it didn't it still outperformed what
they expected it to do
even in light of that i'm curious about
what were you going to segue into like
this is a perfect segue into that is
this the the
wb i was going to say that like one of
the strengths of this industry is that
ultimately
there aren't many trades there's there's
trade secrets of course especially like
with the engine companies there's a lot
of
patented tech a lot of private tech
that's not known but
actually no that's nonsense as well
because epic shares it's source code
like the games industry generally over
shares information gdc every year
if i want i i remember actually like
with volume we rubbed ripped off a bunch
literally ripped off a bunch of the
coding practices that led to
how what was it we looked at was it was
how infamous handled its uh character
movement
like we just literally stole that but i
didn't have to hack anything it was a
ggc
talk you know it was just all out there
and all presented so the games industry
generally
shares because we all understand that
our innovations our unique
interesting thing that makes our game
work is built on top of a bunch of
mechanics that we're taking from other
games
which brings us to the patent issue with
uh
with warner brothers where they're where
they're locking down a mechanic which
is generally massively frowned upon
because
that's not you don't get you don't get
the mordor game sorry shadow i still
call it the mordor i still struggle with
that
you don't get those games without
assassin's creed all batman don't get
those
i guess they aren't without batman which
they own but still like you've got
everyone's building on the shoulders of
everyone else that's the games industry
that otherwise it would
it's all ours
component to the conversation though
that i i i think is is worthy of at
least talking about is and i understand
warner brothers is that their daddy
warbucks right so
that they give an allowance to monolith
who's the teenager that gets it allow us
for mowing their lawns
um anything that is created under that
banner monolith
unless there's something that's that's
negotiated is the property of warner
brothers
games correct so they develop warner
brothers owns the lawn even if they
mowed it yeah exac
well said but they keep all the bags of
grass clippings in the garage too
but the people that did the work i mean
not to get political but you know
capitalism has some
some slight flaws you know some slightly
i can't think of any
um but it also what about this
but what about this i mean i don't want
to derail you troy but what what about
this targets capitalism for you i mean
when someone finances something um
it's still pending a negotiation people
for example it's not a defense position
that if you pay me you automatically own
what i create everything is a
negotiation
so i was i was taking i was taking a
cheap shot i was taking a cheap shot it
would be really cool
if you know the people who made things
got to benefit from the production of
that but to be honest
we're moving into like socialist theory
at a larger scale and probably it's
beyond the scope of this conversation
somehow let's talk about you know star
wars i was making a cheap joke to be
honest austin is the answer to your
question i was making a cheap joke
yeah carry on troy all right i got you i
got you
as a i i would throw it back to you mike
if if you created yeah if you created
something like they did which is was
truly an industry
shifting event they they did i mean you
could you could trace their lineage back
to [ __ ] pong if you wanted to it's
like if we didn't have this we wouldn't
have this if we didn't have this
but there are direct ties to assassin's
creed two
especially the fighting mechanic in um
arkham
uh specifically so it it it's it's a
a natural progression and an evolution
of those of those mechanics
but what they did with the nemesis
system is what made
they didn't care about those lord of the
rings they didn't care about anything
other than the fact he's like wow this
is a really
this is the first next-gen game that
we've really seen something that
really utilizes the power that's under
the hood if you had created something
like that
and you did it under the auspices and
the shingles of
whomever and they decided that they were
going to patent
that can you
discuss how you would feel about that do
you do you feel like that's what i'm
saying
privately probably i can't talk publicly
in that situation right probably that
would be
in a very difficult position
contractually like i wouldn't be able to
criticize them publicly but i'd
definitely be complaining to my friends
about it that sucks
no i think i think i think i think
there's an argument for copyrights and
as an argument for trademarks um
obviously as someone who owns who's
created ip
i definitely benefit from you can't
release your game called thomas was
alone tomorrow right that's a benefit i
i'm conveyed by the idea it's gonna do
the same thing austin why the idea of
copyright kills your pitch doesn't it
well i think i think i think game
mechanics do cross a line i think i
think
ultimately we're talking here about
a methodology of producing something
we're not talking about something
which someone made like the nemesis
system and
its detail and its nuance and the
writing that leads to those cool walk
names and the way this all works that
stuff's all lovely
and that stuff is correctly protected by
copyright like you can't just go and
take all those art assets
all of those all those dialogues all
those writing all of the art and
creativity that's gone into that process
and put that in your game but in terms
of um
uh game mechanics game mechanics are an
idea they're a concept
it's it would be it would be the
equivalent of if you know
a filmmaker invented a new approach to
filming if if fincher
patented the fincher aesthetic that
would
be that would suck right that would
freeze out a bunch of new filmmakers
from innovating doing something fresh
and also cynically fincher can only make
so many movies so like
i want if i love his aesthetic but you
even even rolled even further like what
if the dolly camera was patented
in the real world this makes sense
because if you invented new technology
and you have the facility to sell that
technology onto people or license it
yeah that's great i think the closest
film equivalent
like to use your specific example when
uh the wachowskis
like if c-sharp was remember the
rotating
the rotating multi-cam matrix thing that
would be an example of a
very specific innovation that of course
other films
most awkwardly charlie's angels uh tried
to
use to create their own version of that
right but they did patent right
and that would be
you can put bullet time in you just
can't call it bullet time yeah but the
crucial thing and where the matrix
example is a really good example but
this is true of the game thing as well
is you know now matrix four i assume
it's the wachowskis directing i don't
actually know if that's is it the way i
think it's one wachowski
one which outskirts they are involved to
one degree right
anyway they i'm sure they profit from it
right they make the matrix four
and but crucially matrix four
will be using a bunch of visual effects
techniques and
skill and processes that are the direct
result of people ripping off the stuff
they pioneered in the 2000s
if the matrix had locked down all of its
constituent elements that made it unique
and exciting
then that would have stifled the growth
of all of the industries that came after
the matrix to kind of innovate
all that visual effects all of the
concept in the matrix i believe it was
the first film to do this where they
kind of
made a 3d model of the set and kind of
projection mapped onto that so you could
do the fly around because
of course in those leaning back being
shot by bullets that entire environment
is cg all of these techniques that
were pioneered in the matrix if those
have been locked down
the matrix 4 can't happen because
there's not been 20 years
of innovation building off of that yeah
you're right it would
it would be that's the case here it
would be as though the matrix four was
made in 2006 or whatever there had been
no
actually that's where the difference
lies that's where the difference lies
and that's where there's a problem
the games i got i tweeted this it's a i
think it's a decent example i don't want
to go into specifics because it's
it's rude there's literally a mechanic
that i think we originated or a small
little
thing we we originated in one of our
games years ago
i'm not going to i it's lonely he's
jumping it was impressive
but there was there was a specific
mechanic that we had in one of our games
early on and it's a mechanic that i'm
interested in going back to and doing
more with
if i was to sit down and try in modern
engine to rebuild that mechanic and go
for it
it would cost me time and money and
effort to get to the point where i can
experiment
i bought an asset for 30 on the unity
asset store which is a copy of that
mechanic
and i was away and making my new take on
that idea
within an hour that's the difference i
benefit
from an environment it's a literal
example where i'm talking about with the
matrix i'd benefit directly from the
idea that i
that me of the past didn't lock that
down of course i wouldn't have been able
to afford to have locked it down
i'm the beneficiary as well there are so
many music production examples sorry
troy go ahead
no no no well i i can just
briefly say there are so many music
production examples that are very
comparable to this
see ours is done done done i actually
was thinking about that exact one
uh because that set like so there's two
threads there the whole vanilla ice and
and like the notion of music copyright
is interesting because
there have been so many music copyright
lawsuits over the years that
i think they've narrowed it down to it's
like
four or five consecutive
identical notes um is what
enters you into the sort of the
dangerous zone because there is i think
they do
if i i'm not i i'll have to go talk to
some
music copyright lawyers to make sure i'm
not speaking out of turn but i do think
intent matters like if you can kind of
demonstrate that
you can use xyz before
uh then you um then you are
more safe but if it's like the same
genre of music yeah oh yeah and it's
obviously
that if that's your whole defense like i
just i never heard that piece before
you're likely on
on thin ice like that's a losing battle
but it's still
i think hypothetically winnable but in
the case of production to mike's point
you know if you go to some really really
savvy
production of like hip-hop albums or
like trance early 2000s you know techno
kind of edm early early edm you know the
way to create a lot of these sounds was
really slow and tedious manipulation of
audio and even simple little like
you know reverse you know kind of things
where you're having to make everything
manually and now there's plugins
where you know and they're even labeled
by in fact i remember seeing mick gordon
um shared a screenshot of he was using
some plugin and there was
you know it comes with all these presets
that you can do and one of the settings
was called like
the rip and tarathon or something
because they literally modeled one of
their own
presets on something he had done in doom
2016.
and so it's like if if if that had been
illegal
uh you know that's that's or or you know
somehow obstructed it would have stifled
other people's ability to make it
because the notion of oh well i better i
better hang on and
protect this at all costs i think also
comes with this subtext of i
i don't believe in myself to ever have
another idea ever again
and also i developed this idea better
and faster than my competitors
i want to throw it into something is
even slightly similar because of patent
law is a huge thing too and
to music before we jump to you mike um i
was watching a thing about kanye and the
amount of samples he's used the other
day
and most of his best songs heavily
sample
other songs but they're so good and it's
completely different he's reinvented it
and i'm sure that that's how he gets
around it legally but to limit that kind
of thing entirely
we'd lose a lot but there's also a
licensing process for using samples
that's perfectly above board like
there's no
there's no uh obstacle to that true
two two things i i think that um
that helped contextualize this first of
all
i feel like what this does is it
automatically
changes the um the landscape to
coke and pepsi it's both going to be
someone's going to go out and they're
going to make a pepsi if this is the
coke someone's going to go make a pepsi
they're going to get as close to that
formula as possible
without it being within i know trust me
i don't like either of them i'm a dr
pepper kid if anything
but we're going to go it's not your
formula see what we can do
but at the end of the day it's a soft
drink and that's what people want
so then you start marketing do you want
the nemesis system or do you want the
enemy system do you you know what i mean
like you're going to get as close to it
as possible
because and it becomes a blatant
alternative to it
which defeats the purpose because you're
not the only one selling coke
or as we would say you're not the only
one selling soda
so the other thing is that
i i that is a texas thing isn't it my
mom
my mom who grew up in arlington says
it's a placeholder for all forms of soda
really
what kind of coke you want you just gave
me such a you just gave me such a uh
you just gave me such a like out of the
blue flashback of her saying i'd like a
coke what kind
oh you know dr pepper yeah do you think
people say what kind you just say or do
you say cola
no never said no one would say so you'd
say coke and then you'd say coke again
if you wanted to get a coke just co you
have diet coke soft drinks
like latin animal names which i like
soft drink because it implies that
we base our naming conventions on hard
drink being liquor
yeah soft drink yeah what i like about
soft drink is that
you're using a phrase that's from like a
half a century before you were born
so is fizzy pop and and soda pop and
soda water
soft drink is such an antiquated way to
say it it's charming well
you know things take a long time to get
to australia it's far away true
the second thing that i would say about
this is i do feel before
it's it's easy to vilify but i look at
this from a different perspective and go
okay
instead of assuming that warner brothers
games is this evil you know
people are filled with machinations and
and trying to control the industry
they're looking down the pike and going
at some point us making video games
is not going to be sustainable it's it's
going to be
a um gain prices are going to
going to go down they've had a studio
that has closed down
they've seen a a drop-off in sales
so they're looking at going what is
another way for us to be able to remain
warner brothers games i have no idea
this is what these people are thinking
now i'm just speculating
but to me going what if we did what epic
did
which was maybe it's not so much about
making the game but making how games are
made is the thing
and let's sell these although in
fairness epic also made fortnite
and also epic sell a product for making
games you're talking about an idea
i'm talking about an engine well they're
not patenting the
engine no no no they're not patenting
the engine i i
i i agree with that notion it's it's a
different delivery mistake or
different delivery method for the same
thing it's about
what if it's not so much about making
this ip selling this game
trying to get discs you know moving all
of that and doing collector's editions
everything else what if there's a
broader way
for us to be still warner brothers games
and what if it's at
selling the tech i i don't know i'm not
i'm not agreeing i love the notion of
selling
selling tech would be fine like i'd buy
a tool that would help me do a job
that's absolutely fine but you can't
tell me
don't tell me the concept can i throw
one more thing in just oh god well i was
gonna ask you the question mike
that's a thing that i've seen people say
is that are they is is them patenting it
good because it means that other people
can buy it from them and use it i don't
know how that works
is that that's what they said they
wanted to do though in this it was like
they can't well kotaku kind of shades
the articles a little bit
by saying it's like this would prevent
people from doing it without
negotiating and striking a deal with
them so what that implies is like we
want other people to use this but we're
not going to give it away for free
so yeah so there's that's actually that
kind of combines with the point i was
going to make originally which is
i think the other thing here is i think
we as and this is definitely something
i've had conversations with lawyers
about
patents we assume as consumers because
you see the pace and you see like a
sheet of paper
with like a really crudely drawn drawing
of something on it
and some pages of text and we go okay i
take that document i look at it that
defines what this is
and then i'm i'm good to go either as
you say troy i kind of avoid the recipe
or i call up warner brothers that is not
the process of a patent in terms of how
as
a as a business owner i have to treat it
to get in the room and find out what
that document actually says cost me tens
of thousands of dollars
in terms of legal fees in terms of
actual patent
attorneys who who know how to read those
kind of documents
because the layman's concept of like
what that
means or the journalists concept of what
that sort of means
is not obviously not legal it's not like
it's not like
you can't defend yourself in a court as
much as movies convince you of it
because you just don't know the language
and the grammar of that world
so a patent costs me if i want to even
engage with the conversation
money just if i want if my next game
has my understanding of this is this
patent protecting the idea of a
hierarchy
of enemies who are affected by my
interaction if that's a thing i want in
my next game
warner brothers just cost me 20 grand
just to find out if my thing is
close enough to coke that i need to
worry unless there's a unless there's a
delivery method for that or that's that
that will always be the way because of
the way that patents work
in the same in the same way as any like
legal case like if you walk into that
room without a lawyer
you're probably like screwing yourself
over right like you need
a professional who understands that
stuff because it's so archaic it's so
messy and isn't it like if you're a
business owner you've got a
like a does it is there because it's a
us patent right
so does that apply to people who are
making a game this would
this would be the first question i'd ask
of the lawyer who cost hundreds of
dollars an hour that's the thing right
like that's
that's the problem is i don't know like
i can't speak from authority i don't
know
but i know in the past i've asked these
questions of lawyers and that's the kind
of ballpark
kind of to find out whether a patent is
a problem is that kind of money
but then you also you know yes you can
license it
but at that point like to be fair you're
a slum landlord at that point like
you're just
i don't i have to you know in the same
way as if i'm if i'm poor i need to live
somewhere
so and if i can't afford a nice place
then i'm going to end up having to live
somewhere crap
but a landlord then can charge me
whatever they want for that
again i feel like i i i am the socialist
on this show i apologize
but like there is owning holding land
does not make you
a business person and hol and holding a
patent doesn't make you a game studio
um when you watch uh
but it's interesting because i've
watched a lot of um shark tank in my day
and one of the first questions they
always ask is when somebody comes in
with an idea that's like
reasonably novel but not groundbreaking
and but they're also going to be
invariably if the business even gets a
little bit of traction competing with
big juggernaut businesses that are
already well established in whatever
industry that is one of the first
questions i always ask is do you have
any kind of protection
and the person will say to your point
about what exactly the patent
actually covers the person will say oh
well you know
i'm making an example up but they'll say
you know i've i've developed a different
kind of coffee cup and we've changed the
angle on the handle
so we have a utility patent on handle
angles
and it's like they have this thing that
is so drilled down to
practically the molecular level on what
their thing is
that what that also means is that to get
around the patent
a slightly different angle now is
outside the scope of what they
specifically patented and that's
always one of those first questions
where the investors are trying to
understand
how protected are you is this one of
those things that your patent is
actually meaningless because
you've the only thing that you could
viably patent is
something so esoteric and small that you
know it's basically i think
that's where the possibility is is that
it's it's
i think that was kind of mike's point
who knows you to even review the
document is a legal
give me 20 grand you know and i'll find
out for you but the other thing is
there's the cooling effect just
generally right like i remember i
wrote after playing the shadow mode or i
wrote a blog post that ended up
i think it's the most red thing i have a
bloody wrote about the nemesis system
and how cool it was
but also how the nemesis system like
technically like that
and i actually made the argument in this
article that like the
the the value of the nemesis system is
the idea because technically it's
relatively
not easy to duplicate but like
understandable on a triple a budget to
replicate that mechanic
and i wrote that piece and it ended with
i bet there's going to be
five games next year released that have
something similar to this
and what did we actually see we saw very
little very few games of the nemesis
system and i'd always assume that that's
because there was some technical hurdle
i wasn't aware of
but actually if you look at it it's a
cooling effect um
uh warner brothers have been trying to
patent this mechanic for so long
and been known by the industry at large
should be trying to pace in this concept
for so long
that no one wanted to be the people
who'd invested five years
into something that then the you know
imagine if you're a triple a studio
right now working on a game with this
mechanic
you're screwed like you're basically
just gonna have to pay whatever one of
the brothers asks you to
but and and and i think the only aaa
game i can think of that's
gotten very close is um assassin's creed
i feel like which is funny
a couple of the assassin's creed which
is but that's super sort of perfectly
to mike's point though that like the
games that the idea is ping-ponging back
and forth because there wouldn't even be
mordor without assassin's creed to begin
with i mean it's exactly the main thing
yeah you're going to see you're going to
see a warner brothers game with this
mechanic in once every
what two or three years realistically at
most well that's
awesome this isn't going to evolve it's
not going to look at the the loadings i
i i'm not the first person points out
i've seen this point everywhere but the
loading screen minigame thing
which came out of patent just in time
for loading screens to be irrelevant
yeah yeah it's a whole genre of games we
missed out on because
it's not like in that time they were
making loads of games with that feature
no
they just sat on it it also seems like a
kind of hamstrings
warner brothers to be able to like you
need to put this
whirly dingy inside your game you're
like well that doesn't allow us to
innovate on the type of it's like no
this is the kind of games that we make
because we own this patent and we if
nobody uses it
it's like if if elon musk or tesla
started deciding to make
you know combustible engine cars you're
like you own the patent on that engine
or that design why wouldn't you use it
so it reminds me of that so i haven't
been using it the whole time i wish it
were in mad max it would have been so
neat to have a nemesis system in mad max
um
but that was that was the developer and
and avalanche i don't think had the
ability to to
to do that like that was a very
ambitious game for avalanche
and they were working on that game for
so long so long and it
uh they weren't competing with or
even contemporaries where i mean [ __ ]
shadow of border was in development for
forever um and it's because that's what
they worked on first
uh i keep saying that that's the beauty
sorry i keep seeing people i think we're
gonna make the same point it keeps
happening
i don't know i keep seeing people make
um references to what if
id had patented uh the first person
shooter
um and i mean naturally that's to me
my head goes i don't think that would
have worked out because that's an entire
video game genre rather than just a
piece of an idea
uh that scene because they didn't patent
it right
and and if they had a problem at the
time then it never would have been
anything more than just
this video game idea and it's entirely
possible that they could have because
they made something
completely new i think that that's such
a good person action game isn't a genre
until you let it be a genre
yeah you know yeah i think to mike's
point about
matrix 4 benefiting from the
interstitial 20 years of people building
up
on what the first three matrix films did
imagine
like think of the glory kill uh
in the recent dooms as i feel like that
whole
sort of sub mechanic is a direct result
of them saying how do we push the first
person
experience uh further and which they
would not have had the
inclination to do if there hadn't been
the last 30 years
cover systems just a little niche
feature cover systems
right imagine if cover systems had been
locked down from
what was it well it wasn't gears of war
and then and then gt who did it first
i'm not sure there was a it was a is a
siphon filter
yeah maybe anyway but imagine if that
locked down that would have that if that
if cover based
action had had been locked in at that
point
we would have a completely different i
mean
every every first party playstation game
would be different right like
every that's a massive impact on
everything that's come
since um and that's you know that's
that's the that's the issue
the other thing that's interesting is is
it's it's yes it's a complex mechanic
but one of the funniest things i saw was
when this new story broke there was an
indie developer who went on stream
and had made like a gray box ui version
of this mechanic
in six hours in unity as a fun
messing around kind of thing based on
this i think mainly as a troll
and yes that would not have been like a
shippable
aaa game mechanic after six hours but
how much would the
aaa's benefit from 50 indies making a
sloppy version of that system
that they could then recycle back into
their next game that
yeah it's it's it's it's closing a door
and i'm saying i think that's a shame
official i um with your
collective permission since i know we're
coming up on the end of our time here
we are i do have to get back to work i
have i have to drop some trivia
because today is a unique day of the
year and it's just wonderful
it's just wonderful uh um february
coincidence that we would be
yeah i forgot today is the day of uh
today is the day where groundhogs get
eaten
no so yesterday so the two colossus
composers in hollywood history are john
williams and jerry goldsmith
yesterday was williams's birthday
tomorrow is goldsmith's birthday
so we are in that magical little day
so and today is our 50th br so here's
some cool
here's some cool trivia for you that a
friend of mine
shared in response to that to the same
phenome
a good friend of mine who was a record
is a record label producer who worked
with both of them many times
um he said if you look at the
40 year period from 1965 to 2005
40 years that's half the film industry's
lifetime
um up to that point um
there were only three years in which
one or both of them was not oscar
nominated
wow can you from 1965 to 2005.
and here's another interesting trivia
about john williams specifically since
yesterday was his 89th birthday
six toes on left foot john williams
um a friend of mine made this assertion
and i tried to research it it looks
correct but i will put the caveat that i
couldn't prove it but
if you look at um crew members
associated with films and you take all
the films that they worked on
and create the cumulative box office you
can rank people based on how much money
globally
their films made you know the collect
like i think it's like spielberg
spielberg the films that he's directed
is like a net of something like 10
billion dollars worldwide or something
john williams the net earnings of
his films in his lifetime makes him
the number one in the entire film
industry across all categories
with uh because the the the unadjusted
for inflation
is 25 billion dollars but that's you
know
star wars for example was
300 million dollars in 1977
so it's you know it's closer to a
billion in today's jesus
so it's like so williams is he's
considerably more than every other
director producer
um well have you followed have you seen
his instagram it's ridiculous
like the the lifestyle he leads as a
result that is
actually you know the best part is he
has the most did you ever see there was
a video
there was a video that he doesn't even
have a cell phone he doesn't he
literally writes pen and paper doesn't
own a cell phone
uh and uh sounds nice amazing he's
really nice
he does yeah it's uh yeah he he has an
incredibly
uh by la in the la
you know adjusted for la spectrum he has
a very middle-class
normal house he doesn't live in some
beverly hills mansion
and like it's nicer home than you know
adjusted for all the median across the
united states but by l.a terms
he lives quite modestly uh yeah he's
he's an anomaly
there will never be another jerry sadly
has been gone for almost 20 years now
but uh but uh how old would jerry's gold
goldsmith have been tomorrow would be
jerry's
92nd birthday if he were alive he died
he had
eight years on williams
he has three years one but william was
born in 1932
jerry 1929. i thought i thought uh
williams is turning john williams turned
84.
89 yesterday nine yeah they were close
in age but
but uh and jerry famously scored
almost entirely horrible bad flaw he
scored a handful of classics like alien
planet of the apes patton
et cetera et cetera but many many many
movies were just
just dumpster fires and the best part of
them were the score so his
cumulative lifetime worldwide gross is
like six billion or something far behind
williams
richard burton has a great quote and he
said even it may be rubbish
but if it is be the best rubbish in it
yeah he he was he the way my agent who
who used to rep jerry
uh and and has all these great stories
once the way he phrased it was jerry
always scored the movie that the
producers thought they were making
in their head
that is really good you know like
they're picturing themselves at the
oscars
winning best picture and so jerry scored
that vision
of the film and then everybody saw it
and was like oh this is this is not good
score is great um all right before we
wrap
thank you for indulging my mic of course
thank you for being that was great man
that was pretty cool
i'm kind of disappointed that austin
didn't make another
wonderful musical for us for 50. he kind
of disappointed me a little bit
that was a one-off yeah
but it's different uh but we do have new
match let me slide it over real quick oh
yeah
so if you've heard me clicking um
i haven't or seen me looking at my pc
it's because i've been trying to get it
to go live but
uh redbubble keeps giving me um this
something went wrong area so i'm gonna
have to figure that out this is how it
looks on my back end we basically got
uh honest i'm a big fan of ollie hoff
um i i basically was like make whatever
you want and so you can see like if
you're
on the live stream this is the stuff
that's disabled this is the stuff that's
enabled it's on
phone cases and stickers and and pillows
and
mugs oh it's on stickers mate yeah you
got it on stickers you got it on
drawstring bags
tablet cases clocks i like the clock a
whole lot i think that's really neat
so i put it on my ute nice um
a huge thanks to to ollie uh all of the
uh proceeds from any of our merch will
go to charity and um thank you for
joining us
live hi jackie well i actually asked you
guys wish charity for them for the
record
this month i've been raising money for
color of change but i will definitely
talk to you guys about that first but
yes i will
get that up as soon as i can thank you
to everyone uh who's joining us live
here
um i think based on the audio i will
probably publish the video
as normal on friday um this is just a
live version that
apparently sounds kind of bad because it
always does
that's us and uh we will see you
actually a very noticeable difference
in discord then on zoom for it's very
odd but i can really hear it it's cause
discord filters things itself
it has a different filter system
generally discord audio is better but
it's still
you know my mic's not being filtered
there's no background noise from any of
you right now though it's
it's pretty neat um but we'll go back to
zoom probably i don't know we're all
we're scared out here in the world of
discord so it's a scary land
that's true i feel very intimidated all
right
we will see you all next time bye